hi
i'm shanael basic for quick take and
joining me is anthony noto the ceo of
sofi
sofi has more than a million members now
and it helps them manage their financial
lives
and so sophie also has the naming rights
to one of
the most expensive stadium in the nfl
anthony thank you for joining us oh it's
my pleasure thank you for having me
now you've opened the stadium in the
middle of a pandemic
how is it impacting you to not be able
to fill that right away
we're super excited about the stadium
and its ability to help us become a
household name
at the end of the day our members and
potential members really need to trust
that we can take care of their financial
needs they can
do a direct deposit directly via their
mobile phone
into an account they can pay their bills
pay their friends
um they can do ach transfers they can
invest in stocks they can apply for a
mortgage
they could take out a loan and the
stadium is really key to helping us
build
household awareness of our product and
the trust that we are delivering to our
one and a half million members
um the stadium debuted two weeks ago on
sunday
prime time i had a huge audience that
was able
to see that magnificent uh iconic
destination that they've built we think
it's going to be a location where
every sports and live entertainment
producer in the world will want to have
their events at and so
while there aren't fans in the stadium
and that's obviously something that's
different than we had anticipated
uh the coverage of the stadium and it's
and it's grand uh opening has been very
successful for us so and you obviously
have a very close relationship with an
nfl given that you had worked there
before
how soon do you now think that you can
bring people back into that stadium
um you know each stadium is different
based on the location
uh and the local municipalities and the
local government and the rules that
their
and policies they're uh enforcing and so
it's really hard to know within la and
and within that specific county in
englewood uh what the future holds it's
a day-by-day situation as it is for
every location throughout the world at
this point with the uh unfortunate
uh issues that the pandemic have
presented so we're hopeful there will be
fans in the stadium but the most
important thing is to make sure
it's a safe environment and we're
putting the health and welfare of people
above all
else as much as we'd love to have fans
in the stands and have them experience
firsthand what we were able to
experience a couple weeks ago
the right protocol is to make sure we
take care of health and safety first and
then if we can do that in a safe way
then the league and the and the local
politicians can make the right decisions
to
ramp back up now you're using the
stadium
for voting in november can you take us
a little behind that decision on why
you're opening it up for voting
yeah that that's really a decision from
the stadco team
uh uh the stan kroenke's team is is
making the decision to make that
area available for voting uh to help in
this pandemic world that we live in
allowing people to make express their
point of view and
make sure their voice is heard and so
it's really coming from the heart of us
all working together and ensuring
uh inglewood and the american people are
best served in this environment it's an
asset that can do that and so i applaud
them for that decision but that
that's a hundred percent um for them to
um decide and
we were obviously very supportive of it
yeah did those
decisions have anything to do about
concerns about voter suppression
um i think you know as you think about
this election
we really need the broadest most diverse
view
of who should lead our country um that
means we have to make voting accessible
in every possible way and this is just
an additional way
to make it more accessible for people
especially in a world in which
we need to continue to social distance
and put health and welfare
first and foremost but not at the
expense of expressing
uh their right to vote and the point of
view on who should lead our country
now let's talk about sofi and personal
finance your campaign is to get your
money
right and as we know in my generation
a lot of us get it wrong and it's not
only our fault all the time
i know i just finished business school
and i put myself in an extra 150
000 worth of debt for it so when you
look at your client base
what is the thing they're struggling
with the most yeah so we're we're
targeting millennials and gen z's high
achievers people
that do have second degrees that can't
get to the point where they have enough
money to do what they want whether
that's having children or buy a house or
or change careers because they've
burdened themselves with a lot of debt
or they haven't invested or they haven't
budget appropriately
and so we're really servicing
individuals needs across
borrowing saving spending investing and
protecting
and helping them make better choices
along that spectrum
so before you even take out a college
loan how much
can you afford to take out from a
student loan perspective
based on the career you'll have when
you're done with school and so that's
why we launched in school loans
student loan financing is for those like
yourself that have really taken on a
significant economic burden
and how do we lower the cost of that
burden so that you can start investing
it's really critical to have
accessibility to investing in your 20s
and to start investing
and having the income to do that because
it will compound over the next several
decades and put you in a much better
position as you enter your 30s and 40s
put you in a better position to be able
to buy a house to have children and
potentially uh retire early
so we're really helping people across
the entire spectrum which is why
on our mobile phone we have all those
products available like i mentioned you
can do direct deposit
person-to-person payments bill pay apply
for
a loan to remodel your house apply for a
mortgage
in addition to investing in stocks etfs
robo and cryptocurrency
uh one more note on student debt here
because there is a proposal out by
elizabeth warren and chuck schumer
about a plan to cancel fifty thousand
dollars worth of student debt
if a resolution like that were to ever
pass in the next presidential
administration
how much of a difference would that make
in the financial lives
of my generation sure we're supportive
of change regulatory change in student
loan financing
but we think it needs to be focused on
the needy not those that have
had successful professional careers that
can't afford
uh to pay their loans and so while we're
supportive of regulatory reform and
student loans we think it needs to be
targeted
for those that are without jobs or that
do not have the income to be able to
um to be able to meet their obligations
um for those that are doing well and
that are making more than a hundred
thousand dollars a year and
that are in the upper echelon above the
average income you know that
they're benefiting from that education
and the income that they're generating
and
and they should be expected to hold up
their obligation but for those that are
in need for whatever the reason or
circumstances
uh we're supportive and driving some
type of reform and relief
and it would be hugely helpful for them
to put them back on the right economic
track
being overly burdened with data and not
being able to invest or not being able
to have children or live the american
dream
needs to be fixed so speaking of jobs
you know you spoke to my colleagues over
at bloomberg radio earlier in the year
and you painted a picture of a lot of
people who
were really struggling for in this
period of time
how has that changed now that the
pandemic is further along
i think people still have challenges
clearly over the last nine months
everyone's sort of changed their routine
changed their way of living and adapted
for the first time in many of their
lives they were left with no income
whatsoever
at no fault of their own and it happened
overnight so
we have seen a huge acceleration in the
need for digital uh financial services
that sofi provides offering your mobile
phone
we've had five quarters of accelerating
year-over-year growth in our member base
uh we're up to seventy percent
year-over-year growth and we've seen an
increase
every quarter um since over the last
five quarters
part of that is we're offering all these
new products but part of that is people
also needing for the first time
all of their financial services at their
fingertips on their mobile phone
um and what so far we provide not just
the products but also the ability to
talk to a certified financial planner
and schedule that from your phone the
ability to talk to a career
consultant from corn ferry through a
partnership the ability to attend
zoom events on thinking about retirement
thinking about budgeting during this
time period so
the need is still great and will
continue to be greater than it's been
um for financial services for people to
get their money right
so one of those ways that people have
been using their money
in a big way during this pandemic is
we've seen a lot of people
enter the stock market we've seen retail
trading
like we haven't seen in many many years
how is that
impacting you we've definitely seen an
acceleration in people
opening up a sofi invest account and
buying stocks and setting up recurring
investments and
and investing in diversified portfolios
like the sofi giga economy etf and
uh select 500 etf and others and that's
really important i think it reflects a
couple of things first interest rates
are basically zero
so getting an inch you know return on
your savings or checking account
is less attractive than it was six
months ago given how low the interest
rates are
and so that's one reason why people are
investing it's to get a better return on
their money
and the second because people are
working from home
they have greater accessibility
throughout the day to see the markets on
television
to understand opportunities that are
presenting themselves and start to take
the time to educate themselves
as i mentioned for the first time in
their lives they lost their income or
saw a huge
uncertainty about their income and so it
causes you to re-evaluate your financial
future
and investing is one of those things
that's critical to long-term
financial independence but help me
understand this on one hand they're so
uncertain
about the money that they're bringing in
but on the other hand they're
they're investing in risk right equities
are have typically been
considered risky why are they
comfortable to put so much of their
income
toward the market right now yeah i
wouldn't say that they're putting
so much of their income they're
reallocating capital that was sitting in
a savings account
already there or a checking account and
now it's getting no interest because
uh the federal reserve has lowered
interest rates so significantly down to
zero
um and so they're reallocating money
that was in savings getting some type of
return
into yes the market which has risk but
also has a reward
that's commensurate that risk especially
if investors take the long-term view of
investing in diversified
portfolios and doing it on a recurring
basis to avoid market timing and
that allows for dollar cost averaging so
it's not that they're putting all of
their assets
into the market um the average assets
under management per account
is not so significant that it would
appear they're putting all of their
money in
it's much more of testing the waters and
slowly building up the confidence
to increase the amount that they invest
anthony how do you compete in this
market we've seen robin hood just come
in with soaring
daily average trading figures do you
want a bigger piece of that pie
we we think there's a huge opportunity
to convert people from a physical world
of financial services
to a digital world we've seen a
significant acceleration
in people that want to do all their
financial services online
versus the physical world that's been
driven by this pandemic
but it's also driven by the fact that
they have to use multiple accounts
to meet their needs and soft gives them
one account that's a one-stop shop
at sofi you can get all of your
financial needs across borrowing savings
spending investing
in some format um or some way to satisfy
your needs
um in the in the physical financial
services world so to speak
people are left with having to deal with
multiple different banks or institutions
to find all those different products and
we're not perfect we don't have every
product but we do provide
something in each one of those key
buckets or we provide a partner that can
do that
and so our strategy is very different
than a monoline
digital company that's only focused on
brokerage or only focused on
checking and savings we're focused on
the entire portfolio
suite of financial products because
that's what's necessary to get your
money right so we want to build a
relationship with a member
we want to understand their needs and we
want to help them every day answer three
questions
what must i do in my financial life
today what should i do in my financial
life today
and what can i do and we can uniquely
offer that to them
because we have products across those
five critical areas of what you do your
money
in our goal of delivering the value of
get your money right
do you find it harder these days i mean
you're even competing now with your
former employer goldman sachs
there are just so many financial
services companies coming into
the marketplace right now has it become
a lot more competitive for you
to win um the way we think about it is
we have to make sure that we're meeting
members needs and they're going to have
a lot of other choices
we have a very unique strategy in that
to the best of my knowledge we're the
only
mobile first company that offers the
complete suite of products in one place
with great selection giving you great
convenience and content to get there
the opportunity in front of us is really
spread out across
over 4 000 fdic insured banks in the
united states
servicing more than 150 million accounts
that are direct deposit and 500 million
accounts overall
so there's a really big pie for us to go
out and
deliver our unique value proposition to
and being a one-stop shop a relationship
um approach to financial services which
is unlike any other
to capture our for fair share of that so
we're competing with all
all those 4 700 fdic insured banks
for those 150 million direct deposit
accounts or 500 million
accounts more broadly well speaking of
the suite of opportunity right your
direct deposit savings accounts uh
how much demand are you seeing for young
people these days to be
actually putting money away given that
interest rates are so low
yeah one of the one of the products that
we have in sofi money
um is that we have the ability for you
to have an account with no minimums
no amount of spending that you have to
deliver and it gives you the ability to
pay when you want
uh pay online do your direct deposit pay
your friends
we'll do even electronic uh bill pay and
physical checks for you as well
we also have something in that product
called vaults which is a way for you to
put money separate from your transaction
money
um that will allow you to save for a
rainy day fund
allow you to save for a new car or
college education
or a wedding or a home remodeling
and we have seen continued increases in
the amount of money within the vaults
um and it is an important element of the
overall equation of
getting your money right um but we have
also seen money come out of savings
accounts
into brokerage and investing for the
long term how do you
help me understand that how much money
is actually going away for a rainy day
given this uncertainty yeah i'd say
it would be it would be misleading to
give you a percentage because
um there's there's obviously a big
spectrum of people on
what percent of the dollars that are in
their account that's in vaults but that
doesn't give you a complete picture
of all the assets that they have so
right now we're getting a sliver of what
people
uh have overall and um not having the
entire pie so to speak would
uh eliminates us for giving you a
specific number but do you think that
uh i think what i'm getting at here is
savings going out of vogue
with interest rates being so low or is
it something that people just really
really are afraid of what the future has
in front of us yeah
um so one way to think about your
question more broadly is
we're in a low interest rate environment
what products and services do better in
that environment than a highest rate
environment and it's absolutely the case
that we're seeing a huge surge
in refinancing of homes because interest
rates are low and we've seen
a really significant acceleration in the
revenue of that business and the demand
for our members
second is people are investing more
because that can give them a better risk
adjusted return
than the zero interest rate that they're
getting their checking account or small
interest they would get in their savings
account and then the last is
up in this environment you'll see people
also refinancing their student loans
because it's a low interest rate
environment so those three products are
really benefiting meaningfully
um from low interest rate environment
but our personal loan product for home
remodeling is also benefiting as people
are staying at home they're thinking
about changing their home
and restructuring in a way that's got
greater utility and greater value
and so we do see people taking out
unsecured personal loans
to finance a home remodeling but in low
and straight environments it's really
student loans that are being refinanced
mortgages that are being refinanced and
people investing
now what has all of this taught you
what is all of these new products that
you're adding on to sofi
teaching you about how to build the bank
of the future
is there anything about the current
financial industry that's just not
working that needs to be re-envisioned
from your perspective
yeah the reason why we call our
customers members is that it's about
building a lifelong relationship with
them it's about
understanding their needs and the market
that we think that's open that no one
has filled is this a relationship
approach
to personal financial services it's a
shame that you can do incredibly well
academically do well professionally and
not have enough money
to have children or to buy a house or
retire early and so we're focused on
helping those people that have done all
the things they're supposed to
better manage their money so they can
get it get it right and therefore
accomplish
their ambitions and so the one thing
that's very clear
is that having a relationship is paying
dividends more than 60
of the mortgages that we are processing
and funding
are from our existing members um we're
also seeing a huge uptick
in the number of people that have
multiple products with sofi we're seeing
about 350 percent year-over-year growth
in what we call multi-product members
and so we had a thesis going into this
that there's a part of the world that's
underserved
that part of the world needs to have a
relationship approach to it
we've brought our full suite of product
approach to the table for them because
we need to be there for every major
decision in their lives as it relates to
their financial future
and if we have to have the products to
be able to do that and we're the only
place that i'm aware of that has that
full suite of products in a digital
first
member oriented experience and it's
paying dividends for us
you know this is not even just for the
u.s for you now you are expanding
globally and
with this acquisition you've made in
hong kong what
opportunity are you seeing outside of
the us that's so attractive
yeah we're excited about what we're
seeing in hong kong we're basically
taking the sofa
model and the success we've seen and
invest here and deploying it into that
marketplace and
um we've seen really strong growth since
doing so we've doubled their
assets under management in that
marketplace and
um we think that giving people
accessibility to investing
again is helping the underserved um
start to build their financial future
not investing in your 20s will set you
way back from getting to your financial
independence and ambition goals over
time and so
taking this model of giving
accessibility to the underserved and
investing
in hong kong is is really a a beach head
for us to then expand to other regions
and other products are you concerned
about the tensions between china and
hong kong or even the us and china as
you build out this expansion
um they're all things that we have to
consider and are going to market in the
health and safety of our
our employees and also understand the
impact it's having on our members lives
and
so we're we are focused on and
understanding the political environment
understanding the regulatory environment
and so those are factors that we have to
incorporate into our thinking and our
inner go-to-market approach but also
how we take care of the health and
welfare of our employees
so you had those two major acquisitions
this year the the one in hong kong and
then also galileo earlier this year
do you have more mergers in your future
um
we're really focused on you know
integrating both of those uh
acquisitions that are going quite well
and and marching across our five
priorities and so
uh nothing on the horizon right now but
we're really happy with
the progress we've made on both fronts
and see a significant opportunity
for us broadly the galileo acquisition
really has two parts it allows us to
innovate faster in the front end with
sofi money
but it also allows us to provide
stability for the overall
industry of digital first uh banking or
digital first cma accounts
um and it's giving us an opportunity to
expand into international markets
uh we're open in latin with three big
partners we're excited about that we'll
be looking at
other latin countries in addition to
mexico where we are today and we've just
seen an acceleration the demand for
galileo's payment platform
uh to enable people to provide financial
services like a checking or savings
account or cma account and we're seeing
the demand from a variety of different
channels not just
new uh companies but existing companies
outside of finance
and also big big banks and so the
opportunities
is as vast and as strong as we thought
it was in fact
exceeding our expectations and
digital i mean that's the big word
during this pandemic banking digitally
we still see some of these huge banks
with major branch networks
even at so far you have a lot of uh
connectivity you still have people that
are
able to talk to your clients here as
they figure out their future
how fast does this digital conversion go
i mean
how what what's the next stage of
fintech
sure um so the interesting thing about
the evolution of financial services from
physical
digital is that unlike the other
categories like
e-commerce and online travel and digital
media and social
there still hasn't been a company that
we would define as winner take most
and we think our approach to the model
our approach to the market a
relationship approach with our members
a broad suite of products to be there
for every stage in their professional
lives
giving them more than just products will
allow us to be that company that
leverages a broad-based technology
platform
where winner winner takes most and
probably the best analogy
is what we've seen in e-commerce with
amazon
and as we think about the opportunity in
front of us we've seen an acceleration
of the percentage of digital activity
that's taking place versus physical
go up by about 12 percentage points and
it's now in the 60s
we don't we don't believe that we're
anywhere close to the limit we actually
think
you could see 80 to 90 percent of
digital activity
financial activity switching to digital
from physical
because at the end of the day the
product is digital it is not physical
it's not manufactured
it's not dependent on resources it's not
depending on physical locations
um the product is 100 digital and and
can be delivered
through digital devices so we think um
the upper bound on what percentage of
financial services that are digital
versus physical
uh still has a lot of runway from where
we are today well then are you worried
about the tech giants the amazons the
um the the apples the googles getting
deeper into financial services
or do you see a chance to partner more
with them i think it's a chance to
partner with those companies the
you know the financial services industry
is a regulated industry and
we're regulated by 50 states in lending
we're regulated by 30 plus states for
mortgage
we're also have money transmitter
licenses in order to do cryptocurrency
on our platform which is also available
so we're already a regulated company and
we understand
our requirements and our
responsibilities
in that regulatory world and the company
was born as a financial services company
so it's in its dna from the beginning
um technology companies aren't in
regulatory environments
as such as the financial services
industry and i i think it would be hard
for them to change the dna from who they
are and what they do
uh into that world so i think it's much
more of a partner opportunity than
them being principles and building it
organically from the ground up
because you brought up crypto what is
your opportunity in crypto and are you
seeing your client base
use crypto and gold as an alternative to
savings
yeah um for those that aren't familiar
on sofi in our sofi invest account you
can buy
single stocks without commissions you
can buy fractional shares
uh etfs we have robo advisor accounts
and we also offer cryptocurrency like
bitcoin
and we made the decision to add that and
i think we're the only place that offers
on a mobile device without commissions
all those asset classes but the reason
why we add
added cryptocurrency to the asset
classes because our members wanted it we
did a survey
of the different assets they would want
us to provide on the platform and give
them access to
and that was one of the top three ranked
asset classes
um but this is a volatile unproven asset
and so we took a very member friendly
approach to it
every time you go to buy cryptocurrency
on sofi there's actually a warning that
says
this is an asset that isn't proven and
is volatile
it could cause you to you know lose your
money if you invest in it
um and so we want to do it in a
responsible way but we want to provide
the accessibility
because they're going to find it
someplace else and as i mentioned we
want this relationship
model um executed so we're there for
every major decision they make and
investing is a major decision and so if
they want that product we want to offer
it so they don't have to have
two or three four different partnerships
with other banks and services
and you know more than 50 percent of
americans have more than one account
and it's because they can't actually get
what they need from one institution
because financial institutions typically
pick the products where they can make
money
and not the products where they can't we
think that's the wrong model we want to
offer everything that people need
to get their money right so one more
question for you and this one's about
you
because you made a couple of changes in
your career you went from being an
investment banker at goldman you spent
some time managing the finances at
twitter a cfo you spent some time at the
nfl and now you're a ceo of a company
which is a wide range of skills how have
you found it managing
going from those different roles
financial roles
into somebody operating a company have
you found that
transition difficult at all um i would
the answer is it was
definitely a different environment and
different challenges but
um when i worked at goldman sachs i was
running a business
but it was servicing clients first as a
equity research analyst but i
i still had to develop a strategy a
product
uh plan distribution plan marketing plan
for the business that i was in
um similarly as as a banker and so um
the process of developing a positioning
a strategy the points of difference
reasons to believe and then a plan
against it
is the same process it's just applied to
a different industry with a different
set of parameters for their
end users so i've really enjoyed the
professional transitions each one
has really prepared me for the next and
you know the time i spent at twitter as
the cfo
and then chief operating officer was
just building uh those experiences to
prepare me for this position
i would say one thing that's incredibly
different about being a ceo that you
don't realize
until you're in that position is that
the the magnitude and impact
um that the position can have and as
you're communicating with the company
um it's really important to make sure
you're clear in your communication so
people don't over index relative
uh to what your intent is uh and making
sure that
the team understands its importance but
within context
um so they can appropriately execute
against against you know those
perspectives
anthony couldn't thank you enough for
your time we hope to have you back
really soon to follow up on some of
these plans and uh
see how people are investing through the
end of the year well it's my pleasure
thank you so much for having me we
really appreciate the chance to tell
tell our story and to all those sofa
members out there thank you for
your commitment and loyalty to us and we
hope to serve you well today and into
the future
thank you thank you